♪ ♪
>> MEXICO IS GOING TO HELP US AT
THE BORDER.
IF THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HELP US
OF THE BORDER, IT'S A VERY SAD
THING BETWEEN TWO COUNTRIES.
MEXICO HAS GOT TO HELP US AT THE
BORDER.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE COMING
IN BECAUSE THEY WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF DACA.
>> WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
CONCERN NOT ONLY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS COME ABOUT
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES HERE
HAVE ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO
PRECISELY IS TO WORK WITH THE
UNITED STATES AND CENTRAL
AMERICANS.
>> Bret: THE MEXICO AMBASSADOR
ON THE SHOW EARLIER.
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT
CONCERNS ALONG THE BORDER.
THIS AS "THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
MOVING A STORY CITING MULTIPLE
SOURCES SAYING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING TO
SPEED UP DEPORTATIONS AND IMPOSE
QUOTAS ON IMMIGRATION JUDGES.
IN OTHER WORDS, TO GET THE
GUIDELINES WHERE NEW QUOTA
SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THAT THE CASES
ARE COMPLETED IN A TIMELY,
EFFICIENT, AND EFFECTIVE MANNER.
THAT CONCERN BRING ABOUT THIS
CARAVAN OF IMMIGRANTS COMING
ACROSS OR TO THE BORDER AND
COMING DAYS WE BELIEVE.
LET'S BRING OUR PANEL.
MAD FLAT, CONTRIBUTOR WITH
"THE HILL."
A.B. STODDARD, ASSOCIATE EDITOR
AT REALCLEARPOLITICS.
GUY BENSON, POLITICAL EDITOR AT
TownHall.com.
MATT, WE SHOULD CLARIFY THAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID THEY WOULD COME
ACROSS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
DACA.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
>> WELL, YOU CAN IN THE SENSE
THAT PEOPLE CONFUSE THESE TERMS.
DACA IS FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME THEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT
FOLKS CALLED DREAMERS.
THIS IS WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE.
EVERY DAY, EVERY WEEK, AT THAT
BORDER, THERE ARE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS, MINERS WHO ARE A COMPANY
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOA
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOC
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOP
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TO
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TON
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOO
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOT
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOE
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOC
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOU
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOT
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TOY
WHO BUY OUR OWN LAW, WE HAVE TO.
THE IDEA THAT THERE ARE LEGAL
PEOPLE COMING TO THIS COUNTRY
REGULARLY UNDER OUR LAWS IS ONE
OF THESE LOOPHOLES THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS TO STOP.
HE WANTS TO STOP THIS CATCH AND
RELEASE, THIS INSANE PROBLEM
THAT LEADS US TO THIS WHOLE
QUESTION OF AMNESTY, TEN, 20
YEARS LATER.
>> Bret: I ASKED THE MEXICAN
AMBASSADOR ABOUT THE MEXICO
LAWS, WHICH ARE VERY STRICT ON
IMMIGRATION.
THEIR DEPARTURE TENS OF
THOUSANDS.
>> REPATRIATE.
>> Bret: REPATRIATED HE SAID
IN NUMEROUS DIFFERENT WAYS
TODAY.
IT IS THE SAME ISSUE, DIFFERENT
COUNTRY.
>> I THINK THAT IN YOUR
INTERVIEW, WHAT WAS CLEAR AND
WHAT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETTING A LOT OF
BACKLASH FROM CONSERVATIVES
AFTER THE SPENDING BILL THAT
EVERYONE IS UPSET ABOUT, JUST
TRYING TO REALLY GALVANIZE
PEOPLE ABOUT A CARAVAN AND WHAT
HE CALLS DEMOCRATIC LAWS THAT
ARE WEAK ON IMMIGRATION AND
DEMOCRATS NOT WANTING BORDERS,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
HIM IS USING MEXICO AS A CUDGEL
AND NAFTA AND THE NEGOTIATIONS
THAT ARE VERY SENSITIVE AND
ONGOING FOR A YEAR.
REPUBLICANS ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THE STATE OF THESE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE.
WHEN HE USES THIS POLITICAL
BULLYING ON TWITTER OVER
IMMIGRATION IN THIS CARAVAN
ARRIVING AT THE MEXICANS HAVING
A CASH COW, NAFTA, AND "I WILL
PUNISH THEM THIS WAY TO GET WHAT
I WANT OUT OF THEM ON
IMMIGRATION," USING NAFTA, THAT
IS THE PLACE WHERE THIS BECOMES
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS.
HE AND DHS AND IF THERE IS A
LEGISLATIVE FIX, THEY CAN GO
AHEAD AND TRY TO MITIGATE THIS
PROBLEM AT THE BORDER.
THAT IS SEPARATE FROM THE VERY
SENSITIVE NEGOTIATIONS WITH
MEXICO OVER NAFTA.
>> Bret: IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
NEGOTIATING STYLE, SOME WOULD
SAY THAT KIM JONG UN IS AT THE
TABLE BECAUSE HE WAS AGGRESSIVE
LIKE THIS.
IF HE'S RIGHT, IT'S VERY
SENSITIVE, THE NEGOTIATIONS ARE
PRETTY DETAILED AND COMPLEX ON
NAFTA.
BUT SUPPORTERS WOULD SAY, WHY
NOT?
>> I THINK THE ARGUMENT FROM
TRUMP SUPPORTERS WOULD BE,
VIS-A-VIS KIM JONG UN, BEING AT
THE NEGOTIATING TABLE AT ALL AND
MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT IS
THE EFFORT -- THE
UNPREDICTABILITY OF THIS
PRESIDENT PRAYED FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN A LONG TIME IN
PYONGYANG, THERE ARE PEOPLE
WONDERING IF THE AMERICANS WILL
STICK TO THE INTERNATIONAL
SCRIPT THAT WE BECOME ACCUSTOMED
TO OR WILL HE GO ROGUE AND DO
WHAT HE WANTS.
>> Bret: WILL THAT WORK WITH
MEXICO?
>> THAT IS A LEGITIMATE QUESTION
TO ASK.
I THINK THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT,
YOU WERE SITTING NEXT TO THE
AMBASSADOR MOMENTS AGO, THEY ARE
PROBABLY SITTING IN MEXICO CITY
WONDERING, OKAY, IF THE
PRESIDENT IS WILLING TO BLOW UP
THESE NEGOTIATIONS OVER NAFTA
BECAUSE OF BORDER SECURITY
ISSUES AND THIS CARAVAN, MAYBE
WE CAN THROW SOME BONES TO BE
AMERICANS ON INTERNAL
ENFORCEMENT TO SHOW THAT WE ARE
DOING OUR PART AND OUR NORTHERN
BORDER I MAYBE GET THEM OFF OUR
BACKS BECAUSE THAT SHOULD BE A
SEPARATE ISSUE.
MAKING IT CONVOLUTED AND ALL
THIS CROSS-POLLINATION IS VERY
DIFFICULT, FRANKLY, FOR SOME OF
US TO KEEP TRACK OF SOMETIMES.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF IT IS
STRATEGIC SPECIFICALLY BUT THE
GENERAL UNPREDICTABILITY MAY
SOMETIMES LEAD TO POSITIVE
OUTCOMES.
>> Bret: WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAYS AND TWEETS,
BEHIND-THE-SCENES, YOU HAVE THE
SECRETARY SECURITY TRAVELING TO
MEXICO, MEETING WITH OFFICIALS,
DEALING WITH SECURITY ON THEIR
SOUTHERN BORDER, SO THINGS ARE
HAPPENING OUTSIDE THE SOUND AND
FURY.
>> ACTUALLY THIS IS WORKING.
THE IDEA THAT THE PRESIDENT GOES
OUT MOSTLY ON TWITTER BUT IN
OTHER VENUES AS WELL, MAKES IT
VERY CLEAR OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WHAT HE EXPECTS FROM THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT'S POINT OF
VIEW, THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
IT BRINGS PEOPLE TO THE TABLE.
NO QUESTION THAT DHS IS WORKING
WITH THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT, WHAT
EVERYONE HAS SAID, THEY
REPATRIATED OVER 250,000 PEOPLE
IN MEXICO.
MEXICO WOULD NOT ACCEPT A CHILD
AT THE BORDER.
THERE ARE LAWS DON'T SAY THEY
HAVE TO ACCEPT THEM, LIKE WE
HAVE TO ACCEPT THEM.
WE SHOULD HAVE LAWS THAT ARE
SAYING AND BRING US SECURITY AT
THE BORDER JUST LIKE ALL THESE
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT      WE ARE
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT      WE ARD
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT      WE ARA
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT      WE ARI
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT      WE ARG
WITH.
>> Bret:
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN
TWEETING...
WHERE'S THE GROUND TRUTH ON THIS
WHERE'S THE GROUND TRUTH ON THI
THIS?
>> WELL, THE TRUTH IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT -- THERE HAVE BEEN
BIPARTISAN PROPOSALS ON DACA AND
OBVIOUSLY, DO SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE SOLVED IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY.
THE TRUTH IS WHEN THE PRESIDENT
OFFERED HIS OWN PLAN, A FOUR
PRONGED APPROACH --
>> Bret: CHAIN MIGRATION,